hello everyone today i wanted to talk
about a concept that data scientists
tend to tackle in their day jobs time
series analysis now i don't talk too
much about my personal or even my
professional life outside of youtube but
now that i've worked as a full-time
associate data scientist for about a
year i think i can spice up my content
with some experience
this could be useful to you as a lot of
you as i've seen that are not just ml
curious you also want to get a full-time
job in the field and some of you from at
least the comments that i read are
already established professionals but
regardless always excited to talk to new
people and everyone is welcome equally
looking at resources across the internet
that talk about time series problems
they almost always take a traditional
approach eyes closed
through all the data into some arima
model and some magic happens
unfortunately these models can be very
difficult to tune if you aren't an
expert but luckily you really don't need
to be an expert with dissecting time
series concepts specifically to get
usable results from a time series model
in fact you can take some machine
learning approach instead and also get
results that are just as good
in this video we are going to walk
through the typical flow to solve time
series problems we're going to see what
different approaches we can take to
solve such time series problems and also
highlight the differences between
traditional approaches and machine
learning approaches so you know what
techniques to use and also when to use
them
but before we continue this video is
sponsored partially by kite they provide
a code completion service for machine
learning code it integrates super well
with your editors and even jupiter
notebooks so click the link in the
description to try kite for free now
back to the video
let's first define a concrete problem
where time series is useful
so that's step one
think about your grandma
she started this laptop repair line two
years ago and it's a hit the way it
works is a customer places an order
request online the customer then ships
the broken laptop to grandma then she
and her workers fix them and the laptops
are sent back
the problem here is her workers are paid
by the hour
if there are more laptops to repair
grandma calls in more workers but as you
can imagine it's hard to know how many
workers we need without knowing the
number of laptops that we get per day
now grandma hired you as a data
scientist and you think what could be
useful to know for grandma is how many
laptops are we going to receive tomorrow
this way we can call the required number
of workers to come in tomorrow
so now that we have this defined problem
i think it's easier to move forward
so step two
what data do we have for now let's say
that we store every work order in an
orders table when a customer makes an
order request online a row in the orders
table is added this table has
information like order id the price and
the timestamp when the order was made
for simplicity let's say that there are
no log errors no missing values and no
sparse data
so step 3 what is the data telling us
well from here we do some exploratory
data analysis or eda and come up with a
few approaches the natural structure of
this problem is a time series problem
from the orders table we can aggregate
the data at the daily level to get a
time series of number of order requests
per day
when doing our exploratory analysis i'd
like to understand the bread and butter
of the time series that is trend and
seasonality
so first of all does this data exhibit
seasonality
for this case let's say that we see some
weekly seasonality in the data basically
we are hit relatively hard on mondays
low on thursdays and so on so weekly
seasonality exists
now question two do we see trend in this
data
over time we'd probably want to know if
the orders have been increasing or
decreasing in volume we also want to
explain the trend changes that we see
like in the middle of july we see a huge
increase in the trend of sales and this
probably happens because we launched a
promotional event that month and we see
another trend change in october
and mostly because we changed our
payment strategy
now that we have like a basic
understanding of our data
how do we make predictions
if we think of this as a traditional
time series forecasting problem
there are several approaches like arima
profit neural profit and vector auto
regression
let's briefly talk about these
so to make a prediction in arima we need
to identify the trend and seasonality
components and transform our data
accordingly this kindle notebook here
does a good job in following the
step-by-step procedure to use arima but
all of this processing and testing is
only good for a basic toy data set here
it might be a little tough to get these
predictions right and tuned for more
complex problems especially if you
aren't an expert with time series in
general
as an alternative we could use
facebook's profit model profit handles
missing data better and it can take data
with seasonality and trends and it
produces stellar results that even rival
a tuned arima and its other flavors like
seasonal arima
we can get even better results using
neural profit this increases the
forecasting accuracy of the profit model
by using a neural network scrolling down
here i can see some main features that
are added to this model but a big
disadvantage of profit models at least
from what i've seen is that we cannot
add regressors for which we don't have
future values
okay so um let me explain this with
grandma's laptop company
we want to know how many laptops will we
get tomorrow
to make this prediction we use the
number of laptops we got yesterday two
days ago three days ago and so on
aside from that we can pass in a day of
week predictor for you know some
seasonality
and we can pass this in because for
tomorrow we already know what the day
will be even though the day hasn't
happened yet
but you know what else could be useful
in predicting the number of laptops
tomorrow
it would be something like the number of
orders that were placed online over the
past few days laptops come in about
three to four days after the orders are
placed online so using order information
could come in quite handy to determine
the number of laptops you'll receive
however we cannot add this order
information directly to the profit model
since we cannot feed it a predictor for
which we don't have the future value
i can't tell you the number of orders
that happen tomorrow since it hasn't
happened yet in fact the number of
orders per day forms another time series
on its own too
profit and arima models they fall into
the category of univariate models we
forecast and we only deal with
a single time series
but with multivariate time series models
we can deal with and even forecast the
output of multiple time series
an example of this is vector auto
regression models
the input could be the past inbound
volume time series the past order time
series and some day of week predictors
and the output could be the forecasted
inbound volume and the forecasted order
volume
the main downside here for vector auto
regression is that we might need a lot
more quality data to come up with
reasonable predictions as opposed to the
univariate approaches since we're
forecasting multiple series here
but depending on your situation and your
data one or the other may be useful
now all these methods that we've
discussed so far are approaches where we
treat the problem as a time series
problem but we could very well convert
this to a traditional machine learning
regression problem
so in grandma's laptop example if we're
making prediction today the features
could be something like how many laptops
did we get this day last week
what was the standard deviation of the
inbound volume over the last week what
was the number of orders that
have been placed but haven't been
fulfilled yet can we also add in day of
weak predictors to account for the
weekly seasonality and almost any other
predictor and anything else that you can
think of the label is what we want to
predict and in this case it is the
inbound volume for tomorrow
and we'd want to frame our training data
in this way a set of x's and y's
so what kind of models are we talking
about here let's paint this picture in a
hierarchy in the form of a chart
all the models for which we can do time
series modeling can be classified as
traditional time series models and
machine learning models
time series models can be further
classified as univariate and
multivariate depending on the number of
values we are predicting
univariate time series models which
predict the output of one time series
they can be
arima models they could be the surima or
that's seasonal arima models which is
basically an arima model that takes into
account seasonality
but they can also be like profit models
which is facebook solution to time
series forecasting that you can use
without being an expert in time series
analysis
then we also have neural profit which is
the neural network version of profit
and then we have also multivariate time
series models so we can forecast
multiple time series an example of this
would be the vector auto regression
models that i talked about and this
along with the other models actually
have good implementations in the
python's stats models library so if
you're looking to code this out check
out stats models
and now on the machine learning front we
can basically use any type of regression
model to do the time series job
so it could be a neural net regressor
where these are neural networks with one
output neuron that determines the label
of your regression
we can even use something like cat boost
regressors this is pretty cool because
it allows for better feature engineering
like random force and scikit-learn it
also gives really cool diagrammatic
representations of feature importance
it's really easy to check if there's
overfitting and
but unlike you know random forest
decision trees it's actually in better
model altogether
based off of the gradient boosted
decision trees actually so it's totally
worth checking out cat boost
and honestly any other regression model
could work here too
now that we've outlined some examples
let's look at the core differences
between traditional time series models
and machine learning models for time
series forecasting
time series forecasting is recursive in
grandma's company we thought making
predictions for tomorrow would be enough
but it looks like the workers need more
of a heads up than just a single day so
she now wants to know the number of
laptops that we will receive three days
from now
now to determine the inbound volume
three days from now the traditional time
series way would be that we determine
the inbound volume one day from now use
that to determine the two day out
prediction and then use this to
determine the three day out prediction
the machine learning approach though we
can forecast this directly so we would
directly know the three day out forecast
if our model is trained to do so
so here's the second difference time
series models are easily extendable
so now in grandma's warehouse we also
need to determine the long-term space
arrangements in the warehouse
but to do this we need to know the
inbound volume 10 days in advance
well that's okay with our traditional
time series model because we just need
to keep recursively making predictions
until we get the 10 day out volume no
change in training data no change in the
model now if we want to do that for a
machine learning model though we need to
modify our training data we need to
train the model to predict 10 days out
to in addition to the three days out
model
and this could scale the training data
linearly as we have more horizons to
predict
and the third difference well with
traditional time series approaches they
can be pretty tough to get right unless
you're an expert with time series models
while the machine learning approach is a
lot more tractable for people who don't
know much about time series forecasting
although i will say the profit models
are an exception here
now a fourth difference so time series
models at least the unit variant ones we
can't add regressors for which we don't
know the future values while the machine
learning models we can add these
regressors that allows us to better
fine-tune the models
so
clearly each has their advantages and
disadvantages and depending on the
problem you're solving the data that you
have and the hardware capacity one of
these solutions may be more preferable
than the other
hope this gives you a better intuition
on different approaches to time series
forecasting you don't need to be an
expert i have a year in the field and
i'm just getting my feet wet everything
in this video is my experience dealing
with time series-esque problems so let
me know in the comments below what your
experiences are with time series
forecasting would love to listen to them
i'll see you in the next one take care
till then bye bye